-Do you believe in the Chosen One?
-Yes!
-Where is the next vaccination?
-Aguazul.
Any reports of contamination there?
We've been trying to contact
the local doctor for days,
but we got nothing so far.
-As if it was a ghost village.
-Weird.
Sir, please...
MEDICINE BRINGS DEATH
WHAT IS ZIKA VIRUS MUTATION?
WARNING - DEADLY DISEASE
You are making a mistake.
No one gets sick here, Doctor.
This is a mandatory vaccination
imposed by the government.
Aren't you interested in a place
where nobody dies?
That crazy woman said a Chosen One
told them to attack us.
You mentioned his name, Zulmira.
You said "Chosen One" in front
of a group of strangers.
Blessed be the Chosen One.
Blessed may he be.
What's going on here?
I will investigate here.
They came to make us sick, Mateus.
They are going to kill us.
I warned you so many times.
What am I missing here?
That's our difference.
Science is always in doubt.
Faith is certain.